warnings have been issued in at least 10
regions in spain
most exceeding 40 degrees celsius from
the capital madrid to aragon in the
northeast and in the city of haiyan in
the south it's 15 degrees hotter than
usual
for those who work outside there's no
escaping the intense heat
nya is a dancer in seville she was
looking forward to more crowds after
covet 19 lockdowns now the new challenge
is the temperature
we don't have another option we live in
seville so we have to get used to it
from now until september otherwise we
can't work so despite the heat we just
have to push through
sandra works in tourism and is used to
being outdoors for hours but not under
the scorching heat
we have our sales staff here on the
street and the weather does affect them
but our company makes sure to bring us
water all day so it's not bad i try to
drink a lot of water and stand near air
conditioning for a bit when i can
but air conditioning isn't an option for
everyone
the month of may has always been cool
but this year it seems it went directly
to summer but we have to be outside
spain's record-breaking spring weather
is a result of hot air coming from north
africa
scientists say climate change is making
heat waves more frequent and more
intense and they warn things make it
worse
al jazeera
chandra bhushan is chief executive of
the international forum for environment
sustainability and technology he says
heavy rain and heat waves are proof of
climate change
one should have expected
such heat in spain greece and portugal
somewhere in june but yeah i mean to say
40 degrees now
is bad
along with the fact that these areas
also have propensity to forest fire we
have seen in last few years huge forest
fire
in greece portugal and spain so not good
for spain and as
every scientist is now saying
that you can see the clear signature of
climate change this is climate change
this is the beginning
of the worst part of climate change
that the world is experiencing have
started to experience you know the
science is clear if you have higher
temperature you will have higher
evaporation so if you look at the part
of northern and north west india and
pakistan they had extreme heat and the
extreme hit also led to you know huge
increase in moisture which has fallen on
northeastern part of india and
bangladesh and these are not monsoon
these are these monsoons is still to
come so high heat will always be
accompanied by high precipitation
extreme weather even again a clear
signature of climate change so last few
weeks we were talking about 49 degree
temperature in in pakistan and northern
and western part of india now we are
talking about extreme rainfall in
northeastern part of bangladesh and
india